[Musica]
quando sono entrato per la prima volta
dentro una palestra di ginnastica
avevo soltanto cinque anni
ed ero è veramente un bambino
piccolissimo
ero quello lì come potete vedere
l'unico girato dall'altra parte
ho iniziato e seguendo le orme di mia
sorella che devo ringraziare perché poi
da semplice tempo libero questo sport è
diventato la mia professione grazie
all'area nautica militare che mi ha
preso nel suo gruppo sportivo
ora voglio fare un piccolo sondaggio con
voi del pubblico
quanti di voi conoscono la ginnastica
artistica o pensano di conoscerla alzino
la mano
su cui non siate timidi
ok adesso di quelli che hanno alzato la
mano quanti pensano che questo sport si
svolga in questo posto qui
su forza
bene bene pensavo peggio
e adesso un altro sondaggio quanti
conoscono quest'uomo qua
beh non avevo dubbi
d'altronde jury chechi santo jury chechi
ha contribuito a far conoscere la
ginnastica nel mondo questo sport che da
tanti è reputato minore ma realtà è solo
uno sport purtroppo meno conosciuto ma
come tutti gli sport agonistici è uno
sport meraviglioso ed uno sport che
richiede tantissime ore di allenamento
si inizia quando si è piccolissimo
appunto da 5 6 anni l'agonismo iniziato
otto anni ma già quando arrivi ad otto
anni
devi aver fatto almeno
45 giorni di allenamento a settimana con
più di 2 3 ore e allora voi direte hai
dovuto sacrificare lo studio per fare
questo sport in realtà no io sono
riuscito a fare entrambe le cose
ho portato avanti lo studio quindi mi
sono diplomato sono riuscito a laurearmi
in giurisprudenza ho superato anche
l'esame da avvocato
fortunatamente alla al primo colpo è
stata bravura ma sicuramente anche un po
di fortuna che quello aiuta sempre nello
sport come nella vita
sono riuscito anche a fare un master
post universitario e questo tutto questo
allenandomi per gran parte del tempo due
volte al giorno tutti i giorni
direte questo è un supereroe
come fa a fare tutto questo no non sono
assolutamente un supereroe
sono una persona semplicemente che sia
sempre organizzata e che si è data delle
priorità io ho dovuto magari fare delle
scelte
ho sacrificato qualche uscita con gli
amici ma in cambio ha ottenuto
bellissime soddisfazioni sportive ho
potuto girare il mondo
e l'ho conosciuto sempre in giro per il
mondo delle persone che ancora sono sono
miei grandi amici
ma lo sport come la vita si sa non è
fatto solo di cose belle ci sono anche
degli incidenti di percorso vi voglio
parlare di uno di questi
siamo a stoccarda nel 2017 è una gara di
squadre una coppa del mondo a squadre
potete vedere in questa foto sembra che
sia tutto normale in realtà io sono in
piedi ma in quel momento il mio tendine
d'achille è rotto perché il giorno prima
nelle prove nell'ultima salita delle
prove perché spesso funziona sempre così
dice vabbè faccio un'ultima salita e poi
cambio attrezza oppure o poi sono pronto
per la gara
infatti il mio allenatore mi dice sempre
non si dice mai l'ultima salita si dice
sempre un'altra
e aveva ragione
ebbene lisi mi ero rotto il tendine
d'achille
e stato sicuramente un momento molto
difficile ma poi io mi sono operato ho
fatto la riabilitazione e tutto andava
per il meglio perché stavo recuperando
molto molto velocemente
e avevo già i mondiali di ottobre
nel mirino se non che dopo circa un mese
dall'intervento
vengo sorpreso da un acquazzone
la mia stampella scivola e lì l'ha vinta
da ginnasta quella di non quella sesto
senso di cercare di non cadere mai
è stata un'arma che si è rivolta contro
di me perché mi è venuto da appoggiare
il piede che aveva operato a terra e
purtroppo il tenere mi aveva salutato in
germania mi ha salutato anche in italia
mi sono dovuto rioperare di nuovo ho
fatto la riabilitazione
che non è stata facile come la prima
diciamo così è stato sono stati mesi
impegnativi perché la rigidità del
tendine
era molta molta di più rispetto al primo
intervento
sta di fatto che ci metto più di un anno
per tornare ad allenarmi in condizioni
buone
ma non sono più il ginnasta reprima sono
un ginnasta diverso e sono anche visto
diversamente dagli occhi magari di chi
deve scegliere i ginnasti per le gare
internazionali per cui
è un periodo in cui le motivazioni e gli
stimoli
mancano mancano
per cui un giorno sono con il mio
allenatore in palestra
insieme diciamo come possiamo venire
fuori da queste sabbie mobili nelle
quali ci siamo trovati e allora penso al
codice dei punteggi che cos'è il codice
dei punteggi il codice punteggi un
grosso libro all'interno del quale sono
contenuti tutti gli elementi della
ginnastica e gli elementi portano il
nome del primo atleta che nel mondo ha
realizzato quell evento
ho sempre visto questa cosa come una
cosa meravigliosa perché tu sei il primo
che scopre un nuovo elemento è una cosa
bellissima è come se fossi un inventore
io da piccolo ho sempre amato fare
l'inventore
per cui iniziò a lavorare
su questo progetto
prendo il mio attrezzo preferito la
sbarra inizia a sfogliare i vecchi
elementi
e ne trovo uno un elemento fatto da un
atleta negli anni 80 un atleta della
russia anzi dell'ex urss perché siamo
negli anni ottanta tal markelov è un
elemento che
assomiglia molto al gruppo degli
elementi che io amo fare alla sbarra i
salti di sbarra
e inizio a pensare come posso
in gergo legalese nel settore in cui
mi sto specializzando
e procedure concorsuali potremmo
definire un'operazione di dire
structuring e cerco di prendere questo
elemento fare un'opera di
ristrutturazione
e renderlo nuovo renderlo moderno
per cui iniziò a lavorarci sono
settimane mesi e mesi di lavoro finché
riesco ad ottenere un risultato
ma per avere il riconoscimento che sto
cercando
dalla federazione internazionale
devo riuscire a realizzare questo
elemento in una gara internazionale che
sia riconosciuta dalla federazione
internazionale appunto
per cui cerco di convincere con i miei
con le mie prestazioni e facendo vedere
questo elemento è la federazione a
mandarmi ad una gara e la federazione
acconsente a mandarmi in croazia in
questa cittadina o si è una cittadina
che sta proprio dietro l'angolo perché
ci vogliono solo 24 ore di macchina
quindi voi potete capire che viaggia è
stato eravamo in cinque dentro una
macchina quindi stava manca abbastanza
comodi facciamo questo viaggio è la
speranza arriviamo a dosi e e avevamo
due giorni qualifica il primo giorno del
cavallo con maniglie al secondo la
sbarra
la qualifica al cavallo con maniglie che
è un altro attrezzo a me molto gradito e
non va secondo i miei piani e non riesco
a qualificarmi perché l'esercizio non è
dei migliori dal punto di vista
psicologico non sono al massimo
non mi sento così forte per poter
affrontare la sfida del giorno dopo
fortunatamente accanto volta al mio
allenatore o delle persone meravigliose
come i genitori come la mia futura
moglie come avete sentito prima
che mi hanno detto quelle parole giuste
al momento giusto che mi hanno fatto
credere in me stesso per cui il giorno
dopo mi presento carichissimo
all'appuntamento con la storia ed il
risultato è questo
questo è il movimento principi
un markelov
grazie
un markelov con mezzo giro e valore
difficoltà di che è un valore diciamo
medio e il livello piu basso h il
livello più alto quindi si mette più o
meno a metà realizzata appunto a dosi è
che nel 2019 ed è un marchio o appunto
che a questa prima parte il movimento
con un mezzo giro finale impresa mista e
ritorno alla verticale vedete che c'è il
mio allenatore sotto che è pronto a
prendere una se fossi volato via non
avrebbe potuto fare nulla se non volare
via insieme a me
per cui dopo questa realizzazione e
aspetto qualche altro mese è arrivata
l'ufficialità da parte della federazione
internazionale
devo dire che è veramente una
grandissima soddisfazione per me per il
mio tecnico ma un po per tutte le
persone che mi sono state accanto in
questo momento difficile
da lì poi è stato un trampolino di
lancio verso nuovi risultati nonostante
la pandemia con la mia squadra siamo
riusciti ad ottenere dei bellissimi
risultati perché abbiamo raggiunto lo
scudetto nel 2020 alla final six di
napoli il terzo scudetto della storia
della virtus pasqualetti macerata
quest'anno abbiamo tra virgolette
rischiato di ripeterci e per un soffio
siamo arrivati secondi
ma al di là di tutto al di là dei
risultati
da quel momento
difficile post infortunio
sono ne sono uscito fuori come un
ginnasta una persona diversa
non so se è più forte o meno forte ma
sicuramente in grado di poter affrontare
le sfide della vita con più
determinazione
ora
i prossimi obiettivi
quali sono a settembre avrò un'altra
importante gara internazionale
chi lo sa che anche in quell'occasione
magari non riesca a stupire nuovamente
ea scrivere un'altra pagina
nella storia di questo meraviglioso
sport ma soprattutto nella storia della
mia vita grazie a tutti
[Applauso]